Speaker 1: Moving on. We've talked a lot about
Republicans. It's now time to talk about some
problems that the Democrats have. And it's
a problem, unfortunately, named Democratic
Senator Dianne Feinstein. This week, of course, it
was revealed that Feinstein has missed 60 votes.
Her absence from the Senate committee is actually
preventing Biden's judicial nominees from being
confirmed. They can't move out of committee
because they have to have her vote, but she's
been out since early March with shingles. She is
now out of the hospital. Of course, she only spent
a few days there. She's been recuperating in her
home in California. She's 89 years old. She is not
running for reelection. Her term ends at the end
of the year 2024, and it's time for her to resign.
That is my personal opinion. I think it's time for
Dianne Feinstein to resign. But I'm not saying she
has to resign because of her health issue. I'm
not saying she has to resign because of her age.
My plan my idea is I have a plan. I have no
control over any of this. My idea is she needs to
resign for the good of the Democratic Party, not
for the Biden judges thing. But for the House of
Representatives. We got three Democrats that are
going to be running in that Senate primary next
year. And because they're running in the Senate
primary, they cannot run for their House seats.
So three of those Democrats running, at least
two of them obviously will lose their seats
and will no longer be elected officials here in
the United States. And what terrifies me are the
people we could lose. We could lose Katie Porter
and Barbara Lee from the House of Representatives.
That thought terrifies me. I love them
both. They are vital voices in that House
of Representatives. We need them there. The
third person running, of course, is Adam Schiff.
And I hate to say it, but I think Schiff
is probably the shoo in for this job.
I don't want him to be the one to get it. I'd love
to have Katie Porter in the Senate. I'd love to
have Barbara Lee in the Senate. But I don't want
it to come at the expense of the other one having
a job as an elected official because they're
both good people. So how do we overcome that?
Dianne Feinstein resigns. What happens when she
resigns? While California is one of 37 states
that says if a senator resigns or, you know, is
no longer in office during the rest of their term,
the governor gets to a point, their
replacement until the next election.
Gavin Newsom. Would be able to appoint
the replacement. That replacement
is the one who would most likely go on
to obviously be the nominee for 2024,
which could get rid of the need for the primary.
Which means we wouldn't lose those Democrats from
the House. Now, I know that's a weird idea because
it takes away the primary. It may not. I mean,
if they still want a primary, they can
still primary. They still have the option.
But it kind of solidifies, you know, listen,
here's what we can do. So, Gavin Newsom.
Needs to go meet with Dianne Feinstein. They
need to have this talk. They need to work
this out. Feinstein does need to be a part of the
conversation. My God, she has been in office. She
deserves to be part of the conversation. She's
been there for so long. She is an institution.
But she has also done her service and it's
time to pass that torch. But that torch has
to be passed in a way that doesn't screw over the
Democratic Party in the House of Representatives.
And right now, that is exactly what we're headed
towards. Like, that's what's going to happen.
But we can avoid that if she resigns. And
Gavin Newsom can appoint that replacement.
So Gavin Newsom could say,
Listen. All right, Katie Porter,
you're the senator now. Which would mean
obviously, Katie Porter wouldn't lose her seat.
We could probably avoid a messy primary at
that point. And go from there. He could say,
Barbara Lee, you're the senator now. That may make
Katie Porter say, okay, look, if she's got it now,
clearly she'll win the primary. I'm going to back
out. I'm going to keep going on my House seat.
It may not work the way that I'm thinking.
You know, I could be wrong about this.
This is just my idea, my theory. But I
think it's the best and smartest move.
Let Feinstein resign on her own terms.
Let her have a say in what happens to
the seat. I know that's not how politics is
supposed to work. The people get the choice.
But for the good of the Democratic Party.
We can't lose those voices for the good of the
country. We can't lose both those voices in the
house. We simply cannot. And this may avoid that
may not be the prettiest scenario, may not be the
thing that everybody loves to do. But I think
it's the smartest path forward at this point.